very good evening from Suffolk where the
top story on live at 5:00 tonight is the
hunt for a possible serial killer two
bodies have been found near Ipswich
there's now five dead in close proximity
the body of Gemma Adams was found near
here time in water destroys clues and
covers up vital tracks
it's the biggest inquiry Suffolk police
have ever had to deal with involving
hundreds of officers and massive
response from the public as well ten
years ago this was a town hunting a
serial killer between October and
December 2006 five women disappeared
from the streets of Ipswich all were
prostitutes all murdered Steve Wright
the man responsible was also their
client I don't think many police
officers in their 30 year career will
experience an intensity of horrific
murders over such a short short period
of time
winter 2006 the so called Suffolk
strangler is murdering sex workers in
Ipswich as the killing spree continued
police tried to clear the streets he was
hunting in please stay off the streets
if you're out alone at night you are
putting yourself in danger but night
after night the women still came out as
hundreds of extra officers join the
manhunt Steve Reich continued looking
for victims women who worked in the
red-light district told me they're lucky
to be alive
he gave me 50 pound took me to a house I
told to take me to tollens way there and
of course I didn't come back at his
house what do you think would have
happened to you if you'd gotten out of
it mad about the rest of him most
definitely he's a very big strong man I
would have stopped him it was almost
eight weeks before he was caught he has
been arrested on suspicion of murdering
all five women Gemma Adams
Tania Nicol and Illya Alderton Pawlik
Linnell and Annette Nicholls right was
given a life sentence his crime sparked
a new crackdown on street prostitution
in Ipswich Steve Wright lived here on
London Road right in the center of the
red light district where many of the
women worked and following those murders
in 2006 the authorities here bowed to
wipe out street prostitution so 10 years
later has it worked part of the original
team trying to eradicate street
prostitution
Simon alders now runs a rehab center for
addicts and here we have Claire and
Claire's been with us now for a few
months all of the victims in 2006 had
drug problems so his focus was on
getting women clean and off the streets
instituted to Allen cotton his ex
Detective Inspector high at the same
time Allen cotton led the police in
cracking down on curb crawlers arresting
more than a hundred men in two years a
decade on he says the impact is clear I
would say it's been an overwhelming
success in fact since 2008 there have
been no reports of women working on the
street as street prostitutes and there
have been no reports or men arrested for
coke calling offences what impacts then
do you think your strategy has had on
street prostitution in Ipswich it's
removed street prostitution from its
roots
that night in its which we drove around
the old red-light district to see if
prostitution had really been eradicated
certainly the large gangs of girls from
2006 were nowhere to be seen
but we'd heard reports street sex
workers had never properly disappeared
the next morning I met Donna she knew
Steve right and his victims after
selling sex here in 2006 she said women
today and no safer we've been told by
different people working in the town
there's no prostitution here what do you
think about that
there definitely is where there's drugs
there will always be prostitution this
is Portman Road this is the heart of the
red-light district now well no it was
but from a girl I spoke to who worked
only last night this is where she worked
so a girl you spoke to last night said
she was working here yes and getting
business yes in Ipswich yes in the place
where we're told that there is no street
prostitution yes and as far as you're
concerned how many girls do you think
approximately are working for 4:00 and
9:00 I think so laughs in four I've got
approach of your 15 minutes of touching
this road what did they say to you am i
working and I said no which I wasn't
doing I was just going to score as I
read that's the game yeah do you think
it's safer for prostitutes working now
though definitely not do you think that
someone like Steve Wright could happen
again I think that they are more at risk
now if Donna was right the only change
is that street sex workers have moved a
few yards up the road since 2006
so we decided tonight to come and have a
look on the streets where we've been
told the prostitutes are working here in
Ipswich up ahead of me there and after
about 20 minutes we saw a girl standing
on a junction she was standing there for
a fair while we drove down past her we
pulled over and she approached the car
now we then drove off but we drove round
again pulled over again and once again
she approached the car in the areas we
saw evidence of street prostitution and
kerb crawlers we didn't see any marked
police cars but the force here says it's
committed to dealing with the issue and
protecting the women involved there are
now fewer prostitutes on the street but
a quick look online shows many have
simply moved to selling sex from flats
instead now rather than dozens the
Internet allows hundreds of women to
advertise and being indoors means any
violence is hidden and if the girls work
in pairs for safety they're breaking the
law it's also claimed crackdowns just
move the sex trade to other areas
so I've come here to Norwich which is
about an hour and a quarter from Ipswich
and the reason we've come is because
some of the former prostitutes we spoke
to said the girls used to work between
the two areas and that's not the only
connection if you have a look out of the
window here that was the ferry boat in a
pub which steve wright used to run as in
Ipswich right had chosen to live in the
heart of the red-light district during
his time as landlord for prostitutes
disappeared their murders remain
unsolved street prostitution continues
to be a problem here in Norwich evidence
litters the ground of a nearby park by
night outreach workers here are trying
to keep women safe condoms support is
offered to around 30 sex workers some of
whom had come from other towns following
crackdowns we have had women premier
switch and we haven't had a huge number
but every so often there are women who
have come here to work from Ipswich so
we know that there has been work done to
try and eradicate sex work in Ipswich I
think the danger with that is that it
can be very hidden and we know both in
Norfolk and Suffolk that there's a lot
of women working in door sex work the
murders in 2006 didn't just change the
way street prostitutes were dealt with
in Ipswich they influenced national
police policy
forces are now encouraged to treat the
women as victims nikki holland issued
the guidelines and says pushing sex
workers off the streets doesn't
automatically make them safer we have
got the opportunity to offer some
protection some safeguard and while
they're on the street we have no idea
the scale on the internet if you go into
any UK city and put in sex work and you
will be inundated with adverts the law
as it stands in the UK at the moment if
women operate together it's a brothel
therefore it's illegal so women are
through the law of the UK they have to
operate alone because it because it
isn't illegal to sell sex on your own
but clearly depending on what your
arrangements are you perhaps less safe
so when prostitutes tell us they don't
report crimes because they're scared of
arrest or simply the police won't
believe them what do say to that we
would not arrest a sex worker who came
in to report a crime you can't be
arrested for being a sex worker you can
only be arrested for prostitution in the
street so if a sex worker came forward
to us and said I'm a sex worker and I
was subject of a crime they would never
be subject to arrest because they
haven't committed in the fence to see if
crackdowns work we traveled north to
Rochdale
in 2006 the arrests of curb crawlers
here was hailed as so successful it was
due to be rolled out across the country
ten years on street prostitutes were
obvious and easy to find
rachel has been working here for years
in her experience police crackdowns just
move women to quieter areas where
they're in more danger one night in
particular I moved to a quiet street
down that end of Lincoln Street where I
was picked up by a man he had a blue
Ford van and it's on me to get in the
van with him I jumped in and he says
don't make any sudden moves don't reach
for your phone or anything he says I'm
going to get me on back on you for what
another girl did to me so he's going to
rape you yeah he did raped me when he
raped you did you ever think about going
to the police was not even an option
there is not much point in going to the
police
giving a statement or telling anybody
what has happened because you were made
to feel like it is your own fault a
hundred and fifty two sex workers have
been murdered since 1990 and charities
say 85% of street prostitutes have
experienced violence because of what she
does
rachel says people don't care in a way I
see as when I was a child I used to get
abused by men and now that I'm grown up
I'm still letting the abuse carry on the
only difference is is that now I get to
charge them for it and up to a certain
extent I do get a say in what I let
happen to me and how long far you can't
get rid of the dirt from inside your
mind the guilt from inside your mind you
can only get rid of the dirt on the
outside the disgust on the outside so
you really feel feel like regularly
every single time you jump in a car you
do fear for your life and hope to God
keep your fingers crossed behind your
back on
kort pocket hoping to go to make it
through this one alive and in one piece
ten years after five women were murdered
in Suffolk it's clear many street sex
workers don't feel any safer some things
have changed women are now meant to be
protected not prosecuted but in reality
the fear of arrest means the majority
still don't report violent attacks all
raped to the police and that leaves them
vulnerable to predators like Steve
Wright in the future
you